discussion and you might as well know
that there is a provision in new
hampshire that's probably pretty unique
it was negotiated over on the senate
side a couple of years back and so i'm
going to hand this out and then if i
might okay
for me at least uh that you go ahead and
hand it out but um for me i need you to
email it to me because that's that's my
file box
so
but
and
they might want to say one for the
sponsor
so basically what what what
people looking at this need to look at
and you will be looking at um rsa 417 e1
which you would have been looking at
last week and you're going to go to the
roman 5 b
and you will see roman 5 b
and the sub-paragraphs below
are all looking precisely at the
reimbursement side
and
in the discussion or on the senate side
the exam had been ongoing i can't
remember tyler you can fill me in on
that
whether the final
reports or the settlement agreements
have been filed i'm not quite sure
but basically what it sought to do was
to come up with a
standard
which would
at least show a minimum sort of
standard of how this reimbursement works
so when you talk about and i think
holly brought this up she looked at an
eob and noted that her behavioral health
provider was being reimbursed at a rate
that seemed significantly low what a
med-surg physician would be getting
what most plans are doing or have been
doing and it's going to vary from plan
to plan when looking at the bh
selection of licensees you would start
with a psychiatrist who would drop down
to a psychologist licensed clinical
social workers
mental health and marriage counselors
laid out so there's a whole array of
providers
medicare's process which is basically
the touchstone that most plans use
on the bh side is to look at
psychiatrists
and psychologists and then other
clinical social workers they don't
i don't know whether they currently
include marriage and family counselors
but i don't believe they're reimbursed
directly for latex licensed alcohol and
drug or certified alcohol and drug
providers
what it basically sets up at the
medicare side is the physician and the
psychiatrist
using
commonly
filed codes i.e if you're a physician
and you're looking at evaluation and
management codes those are sort of
analogous to the codes a
behavioral health provider would use in
an office setting there aren't
procedures per se it's an analysis and
an evaluation of the presentation of the
client at the time you see them
and it's sort of a low intensity
claim so if you were to compare the
physician on an e m code
and a psychiatrist on an em code
most plans are going to say that they're
pretty much paying the same thing
same rate but as you back away from
physician to physician and go to
clinical social worker
i believe it would be typically that it
would be a discount off the rate that
the physician and the psychiatrist would
be having
maybe a 20 i don't really know but
there's a percentage discount of sorts
based upon licensure
and so
that is the standard that i think you
will see written out in paragraph 4b
and it's filing
follow-on paragraphs so what it's really
getting at is when you're going to
analyze reimbursement you first have to
look at hospital systems versus fee
schedule
hospital systems negotiate their
contracts with their own providers with
the plans and they have an enormous
amount of power
plans need hospital systems in their
networks to satisfy adequacy and to
satisfy their customers
and so there's a bargaining um
situation there that is not replicated
when you're dealing with independent
physicians
who are not part of a hospital system or
independent
and mostly behavioral health providers
are not part of the hospital system so
they're on a statewide fee schedule as
would be non-hospital system physicians
statewide fee schedule
and so when you're going to analyze
these
rating
situations bh to m med surge
you need to separate the hospital
systems and remove them from the
analysis because they're an anomalies
they they have huge bargaining power as
i said that their significance for the
network is is
is important
if you go over to the
other contracted providers they're on a
statewide fee schedule so if you're
going to analyze bh providers vast
majority on statewide fee schedules you
want to look statewide fee schedule
there to statewide fee schedule
physician
you want to analyze claims that are
comparable evaluation and management
claims sort of low intensity but
important claims that get filed but they
don't have a procedure attached to them
and then you perhaps would also want to
look to medicare and its system how do
they do this and so that is basically
what is spelled out in this section
which is important to know because
people say well
how does new hampshire look at
reimbursement and it talks to it in this
section but it also goes on to say that
even if a plan complies with this
and provides rates that satisfy these
standards laid out in
paragraph v
that does not immediately mean they are
in compliance with mental health parity
so it leaves with the department with a
lot of room to say look i'm looking at
more than that yes that may be helpful
and you can show me that you do it this
way
but that's not enough for us we retain
regulatory authority to look at other
factors
and i think what i'd like to end with
and it was maybe two or three years ago
the department had at its annual hearing
a panel on mental health parody
and they had an expert i think his name
was franks
i think so and he was from harvard and
obviously brought to the panel as an
expert
and
i remember his opening comments and it
was along the lines of he had a
powerpoint
and he led a panel discussion as well or
participated in the panel
he said you know mental health parties
have been around a long while and and
the chair mentioned that as well the
first mental health health parity
provision federally was 1996.
it actually
gathered momentum starting in 2014 with
the affordable care act
because before that time it didn't apply
to every insurance plan out there now it
pretty much is uniform
and since then if you look at the
department of labor site or cms site you
can find document after document to help
plans become compliant with the
expectations and there are complexities
around this
non-qualitative treatment limit
segment of the affordable care act
and when richard frank i want to call
him dr frank uh spoke he began his
comments and i thought well
you know he's at the forefront
what is he going to say and he said this
is very complicated
this is complicated stuff mental health
parity is not easy it's not easy on the
compliance side it's not easy on the
regulator side we have to remember
consumers are in the midst of it but it
was sort of comforting to hear because
quite frankly i think it is very
complicated
and so i think the discussion around
reimbursement is going to continue
as tyler said other jurisdictions are
looking into it i sort of looked into
any cases come out had come out of the
u.s department of labor
i only found one i think it was a united
health case but it was pretty apparent
somehow united health on the behavioral
health side for an out-of-network
service was discounting when it wouldn't
have done the same on an out of network
service on the med surg side
that's sort of
patently there when you get into the
subtlety of how you structure your
payments fee schedule to fee schedule
hospital system
to non-hospital system
different licensees
there's a bill coming over on
a
physician side
that you're going to see where a lesser
licensee is going to have to collaborate
with the physician and you immediately
look at that reimbursement and say well
this person is you know how do how do
you how do you reimburse a person who is
in a collaborative a collaborative
arrangement with a physician
a physician's assistant so it's
complicated and
i guess what i wanted to let you know is
that new hampshire has made this first
step whether that tyler might not even
approve of that anymore it could be
antiquated but anyway it's in the law
and i think most plans have been aware
of that and i think it's a start but i
there's more to come because it is
terribly complicated and the issue of
providers feeling that they're not
adequately reimbursed one of the things
that's very apparent to me is if you are
a bh provider in a solo setting you have
all sorts of you're now going to have
another thing to do which is when you're
when your appointment book is full
you're going to have to and i think this
is good you're going to have to alert
your carrier that you're not taking new
patients and then it shifts of course to
the carrier say well we've got to get
that up on our website
and then another thing i will bring up i
believe under federal law and i'm not
sure it's so on the state law there has
to be some sort of uh
immediate telephone opportunity for
somebody who's struggling to find
a carrier and so that need and i think
when there's a complaint on that side i
think there's a federal turnaround time
that is one business day but i'd have to
i'd have to look further into that but i
just wanted to make those comments
because we're not sitting flat-footed
here
sort of unaware that there are stresses
in the system
okay don't leave yet
representative herbert
you always i i do i always try to take
the simplest path and and get a metric
that i want to reach and let somebody
else figure out how to get there
so uh
if if we gave the authority to the
insurance department
to
[Music]
regulate up to a certain metric of use
in other words they're we're satisfying
we're not no we're no longer
inadequately
you know providing the service
which we apparently aren't at at this
point in time
rather than have the legislature try and
figure out all the various
uh permutations of what needs to be done
in order to get to that metric
rather than have us do it here
why don't we just
put it into the law
and let tyler do it well
a lot working with the insurance
department you know in medicare and all
that kind of stuff
basically you're absolutely right the
department has authority at the moment
to monitor this in fact their challenge
as much as the carriers have a challenge
to make sure their reimbursements are in
sync with
the parity provisions as much as
compliance you know directives coming
down from the us department of labor the
department is challenged with
monitoring this so it's all very well to
say to the provider
you know call us up and let us know that
you no longer can take patience
and then we have to get it up on the
website
somebody's got to say well did the
provider call did it get up on the
website was there's a telephone contact
of somebody did they provide out of
network i mean their monitoring is is
that is a huge challenge
uh the good part is they're funded
they're not funded by the general fund
so
they can expand under their authority to
do what's necessary to regulate and we
pay for it
according to our presence in the state
so it's a system that's supposed to work
and i think the other issue is and i'm
hearing nami here i think they need to
advise their members of every little
thing that's around in the statute and
about the authority of the department
because unless they get the complaints
it's going to be very hard for them
follow on my only my only point was
i don't think
this legislative body should be
getting into the weeds here
and but we've got some weeds that need
to get into and i think that we have a
department that is
purportedly uh got
is getting good at that i mean i think
we
had a reference to us an early study
we were earlier than most states
so i would i would prefer to put some
muscle
legislative muscle in the law
that gives the authority
to our government
to negotiate
up to a certain metric which is
the use
of uh you know people can get help
uh and and i don't you know
i don't want to put a sentence in there
people can get health according to hb
you know
i just think that maybe maybe the
department needs a little more
uh
nudging
i don't know what the word is
but give them the authority
to come in and work with the insurance
companies
on a on an even keel and everybody knows
what what the what the yes is
and and
i don't want to be doing that work
well my my theory is with this amendment
is that
obviously we're bringing
to the front and center the importance
of
the network and that there are providers
there
and if they're not if the pro if the
predators are all closed or they're not
because they're
quitting because they're not getting
reimbursed enough
then the
the insurance department is going to see
that right away but more importantly is
the insurance companies
are going to have to deal with that
problem
and they're going to have to pay more
but the law should say that
the law is is left open for them to
negotiate with the providers
at the end of the day the law says
they've got to have providers
so
that means that the companies have got
to do whatever they can to get providers
into the network and it sounds like to
me the number one reason they haven't is
because they don't reimburse enough
but for us to mandate them to pay more
well i don't know that's like it's price
controls or that's
i mean regulations we don't do that do
we
with all due respect
uh
governments do regulate and
if if we give them the authority
to
regulate in other words say look we're
not making the metric here
let's let's figure out how to get there
and by the way you know if
if we don't get there
then there's going to be consequences
that's called regulation i don't i don't
think the legislation should be
involved in those conversations i think
that we should make it clear
that the insurance department has that
responsibility
and maybe it we haven't made it clear
yet because you they're saying oh well
it's already in the law well no it's not
working so i don't why
and it all falls back on
the
to me the government i you know the
market by itself apparently
cannot get down there
and still you know survive so
um
yeah
okay you gotta get the reimbursement
rate up that's all i'm saying
representative bartlett sorry thank you
mr chair um
i'm gonna go back to
discussion on this amendment
my feeling is that the
amount of testimony that we heard last
week regarding the problems with the
issue is not going to be addressed with
this amendment
this amendment is only talking about
well
it it
talks about just
eliminating the whole bill
and just saying about notice that the
sole pro providers and most of the
mental health providers our sole
providers
would have to be contacting the
insurance carriers and i think that the
amount of responsibility that this bill
would put
this amendment would put on the sole
providers would be more than they could
handle
because this could change from one week
to another you know there may be
one week that they can't take um more
more more patients and let the insurance
company know we know that there's going
to be a lag time between
being able for the various carriers and
it's probably more than one carrier
involved
to be able to update their website and
then it could change
um so i don't feel like that the
amendment is addressing the problems
that we heard in testimony i don't think
we're also i also don't think we're
going to resolve all of this in this
subcommittee meeting and i think we
should meet again to continue this
discussion
um
because i i'm very aware
that's what i've scheduled is that for
next wednesday morning we will do
subcommittees whatever didn't get
resolved today
and uh and then we would exact uh
next at 1 15 that next wednesday
and what doesn't get exact would be
exact on thursday
okay so but that's but i do think we
have we have to get this beast
everything these eight bills out of
committee that
next week okay but my feeling is
i know you've got a schedule for today
that you're looking for i think
that there's been a lot of discussion on
this one this morning i think we should
keep talking about it because i don't
think this amendment is going to meet
the needs
um that we heard about last week i'm
more than willing to let this amendment
sit for a week and and see see where
we're at okay thank you so
okay
yeah representative greeson
thank you sir
uh in response to representative
herbert's concerns
currently in statute
in paragraph
roman numeral 5b
section 1
reimbursements for services paid to
mental health and substance use disorder
treatment providers shall meet the
required standard if the reimbursement
are on average equal to or greater than
the relative medicare reimbursements for
the same service
so it's already in the law the
legislature has already said this is
what the law is and now the insurance
commission already knows what the law is
and they can now hold the insurance
companies
responsible and accountable to this law
that when it comes to reimbursement
rates anything anything additional would
be the state
setting a price
and that is a bridge way too far
um
that we've got the law
they're held accountable to the law and
so
and as far as what the concerns from
representative bartlett
we cannot allow the government to run
private businesses
part of
these
private practitioners
is the cost of doing business
and
having been a business owner i
understand the stresses of it there's
all kinds of things you've got plates
juggling in the air
and you're doing everything you can to
keep them from crashing
one of those things that you deal with
today is making sure that the insurance
company knows you're not taking
new provi uh new patients at this time
yes it may change a week from now may
change six months from now you look at
your calendar
but that's just
you are in private practice knowing
that's part of the the business you're
in private practice knowing that that is
something that you're going to have to
deal with and if you have staff
you know you've got somebody who's got
answering the phones for you scheduling
the appointments for you you've got
somebody
you know doing all kinds of other
different things
and so that is just part of the team
that you have
that you hire as part of your
your your business if you need to hire
somebody else then you hire that but the
government doesn't need to be coming in
and saying you need to hire somebody to
do that so that you can be in compliance
that is a responsibility that you have
that's just the responsibilities of
being in private business if you don't
like all those responsibilities as a lot
of people are doing they join a hospital
network
uh and then they the hospital network
has somebody that will make sure that
you are in compliance there are pros and
cons both ways um so i'm i'm neither in
favor nor opposed to somebody going into
a hospital network but that's just the
way it is in a private practice
you you know that that's what you have
to do and that's what you do
every time we've had new laws passed
whether it be
allergen warnings on our food products
or whether it be some other kind of
how we handle waste disposal or anything
else like that
you just
do it
just just an observation um can you be
very brief because very brief very brief
um
there's a difference between a normative
statement which is what you've made it's
an opinion that's correct and that's
what you're allowed to do that you know
what i'm saying is
if you make a law
i mean i'm not in the business of
insuring a profit for somebody
so if
if the law says we're not making parity
which is already part of the dang thing
we got to fix it
so
the private market's not going to
apparently not going to fix it so
the government has to put a base in
which is what medicare is all about
so
i don't understand why we just don't put
a a little fang in there
the law that says hey uh well chris i'll
tell you what you've got a week to go
figure that one out
i could do it in one sentence okay you
you go get that drawn up and and we'll
entertain that as an amendment to the to
the bill mr chair right okay mr chair 20
seconds yes
as
the representative from anthem pointed
out the harvard expert said this is very
complicated um
also pointed out that 1996 mhp aca 2014
momentum so forth
we're not in a static situation we're in
a dynamic situation and i just want to
point out that we don't have
hospital networks on the one hand
and
independent providers only the market
forces will push
independent providers to form groups
once they form groups they're better
able to hire staff to be able to do the
kinds of things that we're talking about
bottom line we're in a dynamic situation
and i think we're going to see some big
changes here thank you
okay
all right yes representative now
thank you very much uh john and i
appreciate it i appreciate your um
extending uh this just for another
minute um
just a couple of comments here um i i
really appreciate your comments um
represent greason's comments uh
especially too with regards to um to
rate setting and allowing the market to
uh to determine uh what a reasonable
reimbursement rates and i think we went
a very similar way when we did the
balance billing legislation um along
with representative kirk several years
ago but as we all know health care is a
highly
regulated market it is certainly not a
free market type of
type of situations but some things can
certainly be left up to um to market
forces uh to um
to resolve um and
and i think you know i hope everyone can
remember that uh hospital 1622 is a
bipartisan bill
um it uh it impacts granite staters uh
across the state in all walks of life
um our role as legislators is to adjust
be responsive to the dynamic situations
that we're seeing here in the state and
we've certainly seen um and and and
you know
potentially made worse by you know other
underlying situations but but an
increase in substance use disorder and
um and and mental health
throughout the state you know affecting
so many lives affecting parents children
workforce families dcyf
and
and obviously some of that is even
involved in current events that we that
we see all the time but but i've heard
it loud and clear from from this
committee that um that the bill the
bipartisan bill is presented uh would
need to be changed and and i'm very
happy to work with you john on um and um
and and and christie on uh and members
of the committee on that i've got some
ideas that uh that i'll share with
christy and and just for 30 seconds i'd
like just if you could hear from from
anina just very quickly
sure thank you
good morning good morning hi everybody i
think it's nice to see you again
um
anina hansen and i just it has been very
educational to me listening to this
process last week and this week
i think we have a wonderful system here
and a lot of committed people who are
really doing their best both in front of
me and and behind me here um
so i'm learning a lot and i appreciate
the expertise everybody brings and the
one thing that i want to contribute in
exchange
is just the reminder because there's
there's so much tech speak and obviously
that has to be part of any sort of
legislative process it's very important
i won't be able to be here next week to
to speak to the ongoing conversation so
i just want to get in my
my plea for for the remembrance of the
big picture issue here which is the
wellness of people and and
our communities and our loved ones
and you know
when phil before his death
was in mental health crisis we weren't
sitting around being like oh well you
know what are the reimbursement rates
like obviously that stuff has to be
managed but when we get down to the
humanity for whom these reimbursements
exist
in those moments of crisis there just
has to be availability
there has to be access
and
the reason there has to be is because
lives are at stake and so
my request is just that people remember
the big picture side of it that there
are people we all
love and cherish who need behavioral
health services for their wellness and
their survival and that that not get
lost
inside all this other technical work
that also has to be done
so thank you everybody
thank you
okay so uh we'll end this uh
subcommittee and we'll meet again at 10
a.m february 2nd
bright and early
first bill of the day
okay
next up
is
okay liquor
cigar bars
12 37 i see the sponsor here
hey thank you mr chairman
okay
just want to say uh
we weren't streaming before but we were
for the previous bill so this is all
available on okay yeah so open mics now
everybody remember
you don't want to say things
inappropriate
no i don't remember i i know there's no
amendment i have
a um we have the worksheet so this is
yeah i got it i have it here okay
you want to do it paperwork okay
so you circle who's here
and
yeah
what are you talking about yeah we
handed that out to everybody in the
hearing yeah
under the hearing
yeah well there's there's an insert
there
yeah they gave us everybody
okay
so representative would you like to be
willing to sit in for max abramson uh
i'm sorry
okay
and where's don and jeff see if they're
done and jeff
and then um
you're gonna sit in for van halen
okay so you just write her name
um
did she actually get it
oh my god
okay all right john okay thank you very
much mr chairman we're not testifying
i'm sorry
you're gonna you're gonna have to answer
this question just answer questions
answer this question for me okay okay
so
in the wisdom of this committee
when we gave cigar bars the ability to
serve alcohol
the assumption is at that time cigar
bars
were a thriving economic
business
and that
having liquor was never
contemplated as a
uh
a a major
econom or how is to say a
an important revenue source
okay it was designed to be a
a bonus feature
uh so that the people who were smoking
their fine cigars
could could actually have a glass of
wine or
cocktail or something along that line
but it was never so the question being
is if we were to repeal
all together
cigar bars having alcohol
and go back to the old i don't know what
i say if we had sunset at that original
law
are you saying all these business all
these cigar bars would go out of
business that that this liquor is that
important to their revenue stream
uh
i i'm just as i said this is an uh
concern of my constituent based on his
experience with a bar in nashua and i i
represent staple and i brought this
forward
to to reduce and it's sort of a
compromise we after consulting with
other people we didn't you know
understood that the value of the law
that was passed i know i think it was
you and former representative butler in
2009 correct but i think
and i voted for it so i'm not you know
i don't want to repeal it all together
but i think
we ought to look at it maybe by re
reducing the revenue for for at least
two years and i and i that's i put that
in i'm even willing to consider three or
four just as an experiment but i think
from time to time the laws we pass we
ought to look at them again to make sure
they're working and
if they're working fine if not don't
change them if if they aren't working
what we can do either to modify them or
repeal them and right now this is more
modifying the present law that says i
see it
right but
it goes back to what what is their
fundamental business model
alcohol was never intended to be their
their economic mainstream i mean that
was never intended to be their model
even whether 50 that's why the 60 was
sent i mean i think the one time in the
original bill it was started out at 80.
80 okay and i can i believe you because
obviously you were involved in crafting
and that we kind of toned it down a
little bit but
but you know at the end of the day you
know are you saying if we don't pass
this this one your your constituent will
go out of business because he can't sell
enough cigars yeah i don't i'll admit i
don't know miss uh my constituent
involved i'm not sure whether he's in i
assume he isn't in the business but he's
unfortunately not able to hear to speak
today for himself my understanding he is
not involved
in the sakai business to my knowledge
but i mean
he's not involved i don't understand how
could he not be involved in the cigar
business he patronizes i think such oh
he's a customer
so he has no idea what the revenue
stream is of the establishment i mean
that's my understanding anyway uh and i
don't represent staple don't know if you
know him better but i mean that's just
your same buddy
this is the guy you know
co-sponsor i'm sorry he is in the
representative staples in room two so i
don't
you know
are you involved with the revenue with
this company is this is a cigar shop or
are you just a customer
um
the
constituent is you know once you come
sit over here see if there's an op
another mic over here with a rep see
normally when we have subcommittees we
don't we invite everybody right up and
so it's a free for all discussion
originally i got this request from
the constituent and um
i was busy at the time and not familiar
with the details of liquor and cigar
bars operations and he mentioned a bar
in um
in nashua so i suggested if there was a
problem he was connected with the
owner by his clientele
relationship there that maybe he should
ask the owner to get a hold of his
nashua rep
who might understand the situation
better and and better prepare a bill
that didn't happen for whatever reason
but from the gist of several
conversations i got that
the 60 40 formula
was difficult for
at least three
establishments to make the grade on on
that split
um
in an email with
representative allard
who was a little more familiar with this
he suggested that a
55-45
would would enable
easier compliance by the three entities
that are having difficulty
and
i don't know if you're going to adjust
the formula is there any merit to 50 50
so you can remove that difficulty in
compliance it sounds like
that the cigar bars once thriving
business
may have
had a little bit of setback or
you know lost in favor of the public i
don't know i'm not a smoker anymore
and i don't frequently
go to bars or taverns so i'm at a loss
to give you the
hands-on detail but that's what i feel
that
i've heard hearsay that there are three
establishments struggling to make
the 60 40 requirement by the department
okay
keith
so
full disclosure i do frequent some cigar
in bars
and uh it's a it's a great
venue to hang out with people that have
different
political opinions than you do so
and uh
you know cigar
so i have a lot of democrat friends who
i sit around and uh you know we bust
each other's chops over cigars and but
you learn things that way right
um
cigar
shops are competing with online
businesses
i have another friend in pennsylvania he
works for famous smoke shop
it's one of the largest online retailers
cigar
cigar shops brick and mortar shops
are competing with these online
companies
because uh they have to sustain you know
a lease and a premises and so allowing
them to serve
uh
wine
vodka maybe but probably bourbon
um allows the you know attracts uh a
customer base it provides something
extra
uh that those online shops can't do we
did hear there were 15
i think there were 16 and the one went
out of business in nashua i think i have
an idea of what that company is now
there's 15 and i think we heard that
three were right around that uh
you know we're
struggling with the compliance level and
uh you know would you believe um maybe
if we gave them a little bit of slack
and i'd be interested in the liquor
commission's uh take on this but if we
give them a little bit of slack
would that uh you know allow those three
to remain in business a little easier
yeah i think
that would be a reasonable
move to make
some more information would be helpful
to know to what extent they're
struggling to make the
statutory uh the rule-making um limits
uh and i can't tell you what that is
right now
um instead of just picking a number out
of the air okay chief
do you want to come up and have a seat
here
or do you want to
send somebody up who is an expert on
this subject matter
do you have a question jeff
yeah
okay
yes representative bartlett
thank you um would you believe that i'm
having a tough time
feeling that we should be
moving on legislation based on hearsay
i really think we need some facts to be
able to move this forward
right now i agree with you that did the
business in nashua close simply because
of millwater that they they weren't
competitive anymore i can't imagine it
was because that if all of a sudden they
could
sell more booze they would suddenly
be successful
that's the question to you yes
so i don't know exactly so full
disclosure it turns out i know the
sponsor he's a friend of mine
i didn't know that until the hearing his
name was mentioned so
um
so uh
he was over my house this weekend for a
completely different you get a free
cigar
no no no
we do smoke cigars together
we have been doing cigar boys um no he
we got a puppy and they brought their
dogs over so we could socialize them so
um
that i think nashua it could have been
o'shea's
i'm not sure i haven't been there
recently but
um
it's a big it's a big bar you know they
their facility is a
is a bar right they have uh they have
live music
and next door is this is the humidor
right it's a one-room humidor it was
so anyway if you could give us some uh
this place closed is so shade closed i
don't know i don't know for sure i don't
know did he close does she close it and
we can give you more information uh
first introduction
uh mark armagenian chief of liquor
enforcement licensing with me is uh
lieutenant matt culver uh who actually
oversees licensing and in our auditing
uh department um
mr chairman uh you have the this license
type right on the nose um
it is and i'm similar to you
um i frequent and and enjoy those
establishments um but they are
cigar establishments
giving us as patrons the opportunity to
have a drink
um but they're actually starting to
swing
and
they're being utilized for not their
purpose not their business structure
that they should have that license type
is being utilized to
sell alcohol
and possibly sprinkle a little
cigar on top of it which is not the
intent of the license height
we have gone out of our way to actually
help these patrons or i'm sorry patrons
these licensees get into different
license types that fit their business
model better
i i know you've heard me talk about our
customer service base
that's not even an understatement we go
out we talk to the licensee
if they if we feel they're not making
their numbers and we feel that the the
uh percentages are there to
solidify that they are a tobacco step or
i'm sorry a cigar establishment
not not a alcohol establishment uh the
alcohol should be a secondary to it
so
lieutenant culver can actually speak to
the numbers we have those
pretty close to up to date
thank you
thank you very much chairman fellow
committee members um
did you want me to comment just on the
it's good times it's the actual name of
shays
uh but good times smoke shop do you want
their numbers or
is that appropriate i'm not i think you
mentioned 10 to 15 off the previous
hearing so okay that particular license
was not renewed because they were not in
compliance but i do have their um
numbers here if you would like to hear
them
so so
numbers in terms of what their revenue
liquor revenue was right and their
percentage of the 60 requirement
and so i guess
he's a little tacky to be throwing
numbers people's numbers around but what
i want to know is did his tobacco
business decline was it that was is the
fundamental problem
not that they can't sell enough booze
but that their their cigar sales are in
decline right so well i i think your
original
assessment is is spot on uh chairman and
you're exactly right when this law was
originally designed it was designed for
retail cigar locations
okay in when when the law was passed the
cigar bar uh license type was passed it
was passed for the purpose of
having the privilege of
a cigar a retail cigar location having
an alcoholic beverage while they enjoy
their cigar
over the last couple years we've seen an
increase in the amount of
licensee applicants who have
founded a couple attractive qualities to
the cigar bar license
and they're
um
they're applying for that license type
to perhaps circumvent some of the other
license types
a couple of those
a couple of a couple of those qualities
are
the uh
uh the ability to smoke on the premise
and the ability
to not have food available
for the patrons so they don't have to be
restaurants
okay so
what we've seen over the past couple
years is when these applications have
come in for these businesses with these
specific business models we've worked
with them to make sure that they're
going to be able to maintain their
compliance with this license type
now those compliance
policies that we've implemented have
have allowed us to monitor them
throughout their temporary license type
issuance and
their their quarterly
gross revenue requirements
reporting to the commission we have all
of the data now and the data suggests to
us
that
for the
licensees
who have always remained the retail
cigar locations there's no compliance
issues
so the licensees that are utilizing the
license type for what it was intended
for there are no compliance issues it's
the licensees who have business models
that don't
um
correlate directly to that license type
that are are creating the challenges
here
um in in
we can tell that by some of the business
models you know
the smoking on the premise
cigars our cigarette smoking is
prohibited by the statue
correct everybody
cigar or cigarette smoking is prohibited
but other forms of tobacco are not
prohibited to be smoked on the premise
of a cigar bar one of those is flavored
tobacco so flavored tobacco is now
commonly being smoked through a hookah
pipe
and
businesses that have models that want to
promote the hookah smoking on their
premise are attracted to the cigar bar
license type
now that's not what it was intended for
in every flavored tobacco
product that they sell
actually works against the 60
requirement
now you add this that all of those
products that they're selling on top of
the alcohol they're selling and there's
no way they can maintain that compliance
likewise with
the
um
business models that don't want to get
involved in the
restaurant business
they are attracted to the this license
type because they don't have to provide
food
okay so
every
product or their business model that
they come up with in every product that
they sell that is not a cigar on their
on their premise and they have limited
numbers of cigars or cigar related
products everything that they sell on
their premise
technically goes against their 60
requirement
so when we look at
the
cigar bars that were
this license type was originally
designed for you're talking about um
invoice amounts in inventory amounts of
tens of thousands of cigars
now we're seeing
on these some of these licenses that are
struggling with their license types
we're seeing you know inventory amounts
in
the less than 100 cigars there is no way
that you can make those requirements
with with those numbers okay now now you
you've you've hit us a point for me that
i'm a little worried about
and that is um
hookah
sometimes it's just regular tobacco
right
is it not always is it always flavored
tobacco is in there is
it isn't like like i always think of
turkey turkey turkish
the turkish you know hookah right you
know
shisha and flavored tobacco is what
they're using and you're saying that's
working against them
that's not included as a as a tobacco
product it's not included a cigar or a
cigar related item in the statutes and
our statute was specific well maybe you
want to amend this a bill because i'm
not sure i'm opposed to that i mean
if if and i and i've had this
conversation i don't know too much with
youtube but i know i had with the
previous that that your your um
the hookah business is kind of a um
but i i i think it's actually kind of uh
it's a social thing that people get
together and they got their hookah and
and and it is muslim
right so it's sort of
i'm not sure i want to
i'm not sure i want to be counting
against that i mean i i understand that
cigar and the word cigar
and i and you guys are very precise and
using the word cigar
but i always thought when we had uh when
we passed that statute
i always thought that they would be
selling other tobacco products such as
cigarettes
such as you know whatever
and taking them out people are you know
obviously can't smoke them there they
can only smoke the cigar
but when i thought when we set that
number at 60 i never never
considered
that it had to be only cigar
so i i i hear you that that's what the
bill the law says
but i kind of i'm i kind of leaned and
maybe maybe that's not right that's not
right and fair because
if they're in the cigar bar if they're
in the cigar business tobacco business
there the whole point was that they're
selling tobacco products
all right and yeah i had the vision that
they might be selling blogs
and someone would say that's a that's a
smoking device well no it's a illegal
smoking device and i think there's
defined somewhere else the statute that
you know if it's for the intent to smoke
uh marijuana or something like that but
i'm not sure i don't know how other
members of the committee feel about this
but i i'm not sure that that's right
that we're
not allowing them to um
include other because like for instance
if they sell the cigar and the person
smoking the next car they bought there
that's considered
okay
so
so maybe rather than
getting so bogged down on this
50 60 whatever let's just look at what
should be considered because i i i have
to admit if you had asked me this
question i would have thought cigarettes
or any other tobacco type related
product they were selling
was considered part of their 60 percent
and and mr chairman uh you're partially
right because if i have it correctly
before my time
um
i think chief wilson was part of a bill
that the
uh that was brought before you he was he
was the chief at the time but but didn't
go anywhere i don't know the outcome of
it but it didn't go anywhere at that
point include more tobacco products um
more
uh
so he was around when we passed the
legislation i think no
that's going to be under chief edwards
done already okay yep
okay yeah representative bartlett
thanks mr chair
so
i'm going to go back to the bill
um
are you looking to amend this bill yeah
i'm thinking that we want to amend the
bill to include all tobacco products
where the definition of cigar would be
all tobacco products yeah okay is that
going to meet the needs that
this constituent
is requesting
well as far as i'm concerned this bill
is dead okay
okay
because that's it it defies the whole
purpose of the what the 60 percent the
16 wasn't supposed to be a negative to
them the 60 is to make sure that they
didn't forget what they're supposed to
be in the business doing
which is selling
tobacco products so
do the booze was supposed to be a you
know
i got
we don't have a lot of time but let me
tell you a very quick story
we had eddie edwards brought to me an
issue was that
uh bridal
places
are giving and and beauty shops are
giving glasses of champagne to their
customers
and under our statute that's illegal
it says you cannot give
this is this is this is one this is
roman numeral one you cannot give okay
and he says well should we try to
license these people
because they're giving it away free and
i go oh my god no we can't do that's
what a nightmare and how are we going to
enforce that it would be important it
was just a rate so
the nuances in our statute
at this point is that you know we have
we absolutely know we have a problem and
i just put it on up on the web now
that we have a problem with our statue
that we cannot fix we're not we're not
going to fix that problem
and so in this case in my mind the 60
was to say is don't take your eye off
the ball
on what your purpose is
which is to sell
tobacco products i hear this said cigar
and i'm i'm willing to revisit the
statue and just
add that cigar and cigar related would
be tobacco
okay so how do you feel about that
i don't really have a problem with that
good so what i'm looking for is
are we amending
this bill as it is
yeah replacing it
yes okay
that's right that's what i would do yes
i would um i mean if people want to buy
tobacco products and cigars that's their
business yeah okay
representative i'll be quick thank you
mr chair um
it
would you believe that it's customary
that cigar establishments that do not
have a liquor license it's customary for
customers to bring in their own liquor
bottles
and serve it you know
and there's then there's no there's no
one regulating the amount that people
are getting so the one benefit is you
have a bartender that is uh you know
keeping track of how many drinks you've
had and some other establishments you
know if you're there late at night you
could get out of control right so
one benefit of having oversight just
real quick um
the uh 60 includes
uh cigars humidors cigar cutters cigar
cases lighters and ashtrays that's it
and then it says keno mail order
internet sales as well as revenue
generated from other tobacco sales in
store including cigarettes loose tobacco
shall not be used to determine
whether it satisfies so right that would
be the adjustment
okay
you have any
good reason why we shouldn't maybe re
revisit those numbers revisit those
categories you bring up a good point mr
chairman and and it's something that we
can all look at
collectively and and see the way the
pros and the cons
okay like we do with everything so
uh in that way he just read to me are
they barred from selling cigarettes
right they're not
you have to read the sentence again did
it say yes paragraph two section d says
does not allow cigarette smoking or
service of food on the premises right
cigarette smoking right but in terms of
this
you can stay can sell cigarettes right
tobacco products right yes curtis
they're selling tobacco products right
that's correct two different sections
okay
okay all right
all right so if you you think that might
be okay with you guys that we just
change what
and that way it solves this problem i i
think big time would probably solve the
problem because i'm sure they're selling
a lot of cigarettes
how about lottery tickets do they sell
lottery tickets i'm not tracking lottery
tickets
okay
all right so we will take the revenue
from yes
you know mr chair thank you i have a
question why is it so important that
um
again that these
assuming we kept the same law that they
keep to that sixty percent for cigars i
mean it seems to me that
you know five ten years ago cigars were
very a very in thing
and that popularity has just dipped down
so i think holding people to those
companies or businesses to those
those uh standards of yesterday
it just doesn't seem to me to make sense
in the first place good so it sounds
like you agree with us that we shouldn't
amend this law
i agree yeah okay
okay
all right so we will uh john yeah okay
just in response to representative
bartlett's question i'm not sure how my
constituent would feel about this
amendment and i wish he was here today
to respond but i understand if it's the
will of the committee because i
understand
you you may introduce a bill but it
actually becomes your bill and if you
want to do anything amend it to deal
i mean i suppose
not an expert on the issue so i'm also
learning so you can certainly tell him
he can watch it on the uh up on youtube
and hear how we got here where we are
all right understand representative
right well yeah
i don't think this bill should be
amended i think it should should just be
killed
and um i also uh believe that
as a business owner if they're not
making ends meet if they're not you know
making any money then change the
business model
that's what i suggest
not the law right no but the the what
we're finding here is is that they might
actually be doing very
well other than selling some other other
tobacco products
okay and there is a cost to to the one
right they have to they have to get a
liquor license when how much is their
liquor license
it's 840 840. but they also have a
retail tobacco license every cigar bar
and they have to have their tobacco
license anyways right which is six
dollars but and it's six dollars only
because they have the booze portion if
they didn't it would be
hundred and forty dollars
if i understand the new the new law
okay so we will schedule a subcommittee
uh on this yes representative um i just
want to be clear that i am definitely
opposed to the bill as it stands i am
too if you are amending it just to
change that other tobacco products can
be included in the um 60 60 i don't
really have a problem with that
right i'm glad to hear we'll have a
bipartisan solution the bill itself i am
definitely opposing no i agree with you
yes okay i think we're i think we're
there okay
yes mark just really quick mr chairman
and i
representative i really appreciate the
the test quality of a sunset
but i'd have to say that any time we
hear sunset in the regulatory world
if it doesn't come to fruition after the
sunset
it is for a lack of a better term a
horror show to get them back into
compliance so i just would like
everybody to think about that when we
think sunsets that's all i i like the
idea though but it it does create some
dynamics
thank you very much okay are we all set
oh representative herbert's got a quick
question right yes
840 for a liquor license
did i hear correctly 840 for the
cigar bar
okay so
a liquor license correct
so
there are selling booths is there any
restriction on
how much boost they can sell
well right now it's this 60 of the
quarterly gross revenue has to come from
the cigars or scar related products so
so chris offline i'll explain to you
why why people would actually want to do
that
so
okay
so the subcommittee the subcommittee
will be at 10 30
uh february 2nd
and hopefully we'll have an amendment
drawn up
all right great
you got that on the sheet yeah
believe in me they will be involved in
drawing up the amendment
at least aiden will be
and
start working on it now aiden if you're
online
so okay just to be clear so that will be
in a minute but you'll take care of it
we're going to yes we'll take care of
yes
unlike some other committees when we own
a bill we own the amendment too
when we on the bill we own the amendment
right yeah and i understand we would
never rely on the sponsor to have to
produce that all right thank you very
much i'm not sure whether i can be here
next week but i'll try to and i'll
certainly inform my constitution of what
went on what's going on that's right
okay thank you very much for your time
mr chairman members of the committee all
right great all right so we got
of course eliminating the enforcement
division
so
peter you want to come home
come on up
uh
good morning
good morning mr chairman i have
representative griffin here also should
you need his expertise and i
someone was kind enough to forward to me
the minutes of the discussion last week
and
i've never seen such good minutes so i'm
not sure
he's the man yeah unbelievable it's uh
precise but
i had to say that i guess to start out
so i'm here to i guess answer any
further i would say finance would have
very good minutes
well i clerked for one of the divisions
for three terms i've never seen um
[Laughter]
nothing like that
anyway at any rate
so i certainly answer any questions well
i'm thinking we should just interim
study this bill are you how do you feel
about that i'm good with that it there's
an awful lot of issues i think
um
probably more than we could
discuss today
as i said in my testimony last week
there are a number of us that feel that
having an enforcement
arm for an agency that was supposed to
sell booze and kind of take care of the
selling and overseeing to have a
uniformed
division within liquor seems kind of a
stretch
especially the
extra jurisdictional issues that have
come up but i'm certainly happy to
entertain that idea of interim study all
right representative bartlett thank you
mr chair thanks for being here i just
have to ask i know that there was a
a little meeting after the public
hearing last week and i was hoping that
it was constructive can you tell me
whether you were able to have a good
discussion
yes i guess fortunately there wasn't an
open mic no it was a hot mic but
it was very constructive
representative hatch and i discussed
with mark the chief and others from the
liquor commission some issues that we
had
there's obviously been some
miscommunication some reports are going
to different agencies or committees they
weren't coming to fiscal and finance
a lot of things were discussed i think
we discussed matters for over a half an
hour but
there's still a lot more to discuss well
good it's a good start though it was a
good start thanks for asking the
question sure
anybody else in the
comments or thoughts
okay
um
let's see here
uh well let's say uh representative hunt
seconded uh by representative bartlett
or patricik
moose
interim study
is there any discussion on the motion
seeing none all those in favor raise
your hand
all those opposed
okay
is that a post herbert
yes
oh
too bad you can't vote
okay all right with that
we're done
thank you mr chairman
thank you for
entertaining
the motion
okay
uh so i think we're done
till 1 15.
am i right
yes ok
ok
[Music]
this is
okay
two hours going to tandies yep
you son of a
sir
first amendment
free speech
yes
is
you shouldn't have to go any further
and i've been talking
south africa
myself
a changer
okay
but if somebody had really looked at
them
is
um
dude
right before coming in here
is
town
you
[Music]
we didn't get any amendments yet right
right okay
oh you don't have 1503
oh
three oh two is the ucc one that they're
gonna work on
sure
okay so
so here's where we're at
um so 1502
is going to be the big bear
um
the
status of it is right now um we have the
uniform
law
commissions that was
with the ucl
foundation the uniform law
foundation council something like that
they uh have their uh rendition um it
isn't technically hasn't been
the uh official
uh put to bed sleep one uh version
but that they have given us permission
to go forward with it
so this is uh so just to remind
everybody what ucc is
so most of us are somewhat aware of ucc
when we uh
with car loan
documented you sign
and uh but the ucc if you were to look
over in our statutes is a big huge
section of the law
they are hundreds of pages long
and the goal of it was that instead of
having one federal law have a federal
law
that each state would do the laying of
the hands and pass
a uniform law so that it's true uniform
among all 50 states and they usually
give you a couple year window
to try to get them enacted
and uh but that one of the goals of the
uniform is that it's consistent
from state to state
in this case uh
the it affects really two divisions we
have banking and securities
uh in terms of the effects
so what we have done so far
in terms of working on amendments
um
we've
the concept is that the
um
the language in
uh which one had the banking language
1502 right so so so we're just going to
take out uh
the entire 1502
and replace it
with this ucc statute
um
legislative services is totally freaked
out
and
i just had a
uh interesting conversation with him and
i will i'm gonna go to the speaker and
ask him to see if we least
did not have this as an early bill if we
can change the getting delayed this
getting this bill out of the committee
otherwise what we'll end up doing is we
will stick in it any parts where
they're a little unsure
we're going to say
the
expectation is the banking department
and the securities divisions would come
back for answers for those for next
legislative session
so which is awkward and not something
i'm too crazy about yes representative
bartlett
i'm sorry to be dense um so 1502
we're going to put aside
so well at this moment we can't we don't
have the amendment drawn up but 1502 the
initial intent of 1502 was to create a
new division within the banking
department
and i think that was generally agreed by
everybody a crazy uh you know excuse me
not a good idea yes
i could be wrong i don't mean to correct
the chair i think 1504 would have
definitely required a new banking uh
department a new department in the
banking that was that was a special
but the 1502 had to do with existing
banks and so forth right is that right
okay okay still confused
so 1502 we don't have an amendment for
it yet is that correct correct we're
expecting an amendment
like i say is is um
they're working on it
but that to
do an amendment uh you know they're
they're freaking out because it's a
hundred pages long it's 102 pages
and there's a bunch of things in there
where they say
fitted in to conform to current statute
so that that is somewhat problematic
because they're not necessarily sure
where it would fit and they would have
to
work with banking and securities to make
sure those things fit to whatever is in
the current stack okay so that's 1502 so
we're not going to deal with that right
now so this at this moment i just want
everybody to be be forewarned that a is
that we do have a we're working on an
amendment for it
and it will uh affect the ucc section of
the law it's a new chapter 12 i think is
12 12 of the ucc statute
and um
but that that we're i'm going to ask the
speaker to wait
have waived the fact that it needs to go
to a second committee
because we would be taking out of it of
the reason that it was supposed to
create a second committee which was to
um
well because i see the other one was uh
relative to special purpose depository
institutions
1504 was that the one that created a new
division
[Music]
yeah yeah that's fine well you might
want to go to the microphone because
okay so people people at home can hear
you so this is
well i thought we weren't streaming oh
so
um this you're asking the speaker to
waive a second committee request
because you're removing the need to what
and out of 1500
make sure i get it right so what was in
1502 okay 1502 was amending the ucc
50 it worked i believe i don't want to
put words
but i believe the intent was the 1502
and 1504 were kind of
to go together
so we did one fiscal note
that was identical for 1502 and 1504.
and if you amend it to have the ucc it
will
i think remove the fiscal note
correct because it would be and and in
let alone the fact that that the real
fiscal politic the 1504
but that we will we do want to kill that
okay so we're going to keep working on
1502 after keep working on 1502 correct
representative herbert
um ucc
uniform commercial code is is that a
federal law
no that's the whole point
it's a ucc uh is uh it there's the
uniform commercial foundation
what's the uc
fl
law commission that's right uniform law
commission
which is uh in this case this document i
see 25 lawyers and
and we actually have one person in new
hampshire
which i don't see him here
again he's m.i.a
and uh but anyway so if uh what this is
is
that they didn't fat pass any federal
laws and this is uh so this is your
in-state law right
and if you were to go look at our rsas
you'll see it says ucc on it
and there's uh one through
eight right now i guess there's
something like
nine was there wasn't a nine okay
there is a nine and i would say over the
years chris
um it would randomly they they would
they would rewrite this the code
sometimes yeah so i would say in my in
my 30 years i think i've seen it twice
maybe three times where they kind of
rewrote the statute
and i would always back then tara
reardon was on the committee and she was
our only lawyer so i'd always make tara
read it
but the idea of it is that it's a it's
truly a model legislation model and then
each state passes this model
so the ul law the uniform law commission
law commission works on the ucc is that
correct corrects the create ucc correct
yes represent west
yeah
i thought i read somewhere that they
were actually setting up a whole new
article to deal with uh
they are cryptocurrency so when will
that be coming out we're we're going to
be we're hoping to be the very first
state to pass it so you don't know you
don't have a timeline on it we have a
model they have what uh i guess it's
their
i don't know it's not their final
edition but it's their their uh
preliminary
one
that's been out for over a year right
it's it's actually been around almost
close to two years it's been floating
around
and they've been waiting getting
comments from anybody who cares
and uh but that they're they're they're
very right to actually release it so you
when we see this amendment this hundred
page amendment is that going to be
the new part of the ucc that will be the
new part section 12 correct okay thank
you
yes representative yes um
the three bills closely related if for
some reason we're unable to address one
of them
does that mean that the other two
that they can each be they can each be
handled separately well the key element
was that the one that was problematic
was 1504
okay
okay because that one's create a new
division in the banking department and
that's the one that generated the awful
you know fiscal note and
so what for all intents and purposes we
will at some point in time entertain a
motion to kill 1504
or interim studies
1504 so 1504 is not what we want 1502
um and 1503 is what we're working on and
we have an amendment for 1503 in your
pause right now
yes representative herbert so if i'm my
understanding is correct
ucc
um
is is is not a federal law but
it is
a law code that has been adopted
uniformly
by all 50 states by all 50 states
correct
so this
document
your this amendment that you're
talking about right now
is uh an amendment to that ucc code that
affects all 50 states
it doesn't affect all 50 states and only
affects new hampshire because we have no
control though
so
the language what we're adopting is the
one that they are going to propose for
all 50 states
the uniform
law
commission
so is the uniform lock i'm sorry
further
yeah i'm just this is the subcommittee
we don't we don't have all of our
commission is
an adjunct to the ucc
yeah why don't you want to yeah
[Laughter]
so the uniform law commission proposes
articles of the ucc it kind of comes out
in chapters right there's like one two
three four to nine right now i believe
right nine nine that is the right number
um and um states get to adopt two can
choose the legislature can choose to
adopt them or not or not um and i
believe all 50 states
have adopted one through nine
yes
um
and we're not sure what happened to
articles 10 and 11. i don't i'm not a
ucc expert so we don't know
they don't know either
and so then um now they're proposing
article 12 to deal with um
oh gosh and i'm going to forget the term
for it but they have a technical term
that basically blockchain
yeah and how um you can
treat it like a um commercial instrument
basically
um and so they've now proposed they're
drafting article 12 they've given us
permission
to to
the state of new hampshire permission to
adopt adopt it if you guys so choose
so one further question just so i get
this straight one through nine has
nothing to do with uh crypto well so
okay so
article nine has i i'm really not the
person to ask about this but parts of
article 12
parts of the proposal do affect the
other articles a little bit because
there is some overlap particularly i
think with article nine
um but that's kind of the end of my
expertise on this right and that and
that's actually the biggest difficulty
we're having right at the moment is
because there is some overlap
interlapping between
is this issue of uh
a a
proposal to amend
a problem just in new hampshire or is it
elsewhere as
well well this is a problem for us
because we have a bill in front of us
so most all the other states are are
sitting there on their hands waiting
for the final approval
of article 12.
but we're not waiting we're moving full
steam ahead
now you really got me confused so we got
we have 50 states of the other 49 states
done on this already uh we texas didn't
texas pass something didn't i hear texas
pass something no no
no okay so
wait okay so i didn't get texas did pass
something right they
but they were they they would do 12
light they didn't really
they didn't really take the language of
12 is that
so
yes from our understanding they they
kind of whittled it down and kept it to
not not emerging technologies but
digital currency where i think what
we're what you're doing bitcoin talking
today about is the full adoption right
the ucc and we do have uh we just
received this from um our our national
trade organization uh uh a powerpoint
about
the ucc and what the work of the ulc
well the best thing to do is make sure
that that's emailed to all the committee
members i could do that for sure yeah
that would that would probably work
better
because that we don't want to or that
color print that might you know the
printer might
not you would burn through our blue ink
okay
i don't know whose right hand it was at
first um
just
one one thing rather than having that
powerpoint
pointed to us or sent to us can we get
it today so we can look at it and
discuss it number one number two
my understanding is we're getting rid of
1504 and those attributes are going to
go into
1502 because those bills were very
similar is that correct keith
yeah go ahead
there it goes
oh
so
i think i understood your question or i
think i retained it uh 1504 is going to
basically go away for all intents and
purposes that's a whole new uh charter
concept for
something called a special purpose
depository institution
deals with our existing banking
structure
so it's not something new the original
so we're talking about taking the
original 1502
getting ahead of the ucc changes that
are inevitably coming
and being the first state to adopt it
and i think everybody's on board with
that concept
so you know we're going to get out ahead
of
this change that is coming in the ucc
code because the draft is pretty much
finalized if there's any tweaks to be
made that will happen when we adopt the
whole
new replacement of the ucc that will
supersede this
that's my understanding
well i think my second thing was could
we get that powerpoint now
so that we could
take a look at it and discuss it i mean
you don't have to email it can they copy
it
what's the rush
i don't know if it's feasible to get it
right now all right
representative bartlett
um correct me if i'm wrong but
new hampshire for the most part doesn't
like being first in the nation other
than the primary in guns i mean why why
do we want to be first in the nation on
this
do we want to be last in the nation or
well no i'm not saying i mean there's a
difference between first out of 50
states and and being last out of 50
states
um
when it comes to innovation and in this
case it's financial innovation the the
the states that move first attract that
industry that's the advantage if we're
middle of the road or we're stragglers
we will be picking up crumbs on this
industry and it's it's a significant
uh industry that's actually a global
industry so that's the advantage it's
when you're dealing with innovation you
want to be first
you don't want to move fast and break
things you want to be deliberate about
it and i think
this compromise with the ucc they've
already deliberated on it um i've seen a
draft that we could send that to the
whole committee of the ucc
uh proposal
so they've deliberated on it for a year
or two now um and so they've kind of
done the work for us and we can we can
be
innovative by adopting that and attract
that industry so this is completely
different than the wyoming bill you were
talking about last week is that correct
i think the wyoming legislation most
likely informed the ucc commission i can
i see there's there's a member at least
one member from wyoming on the
commission so
i wouldn't say it's
um
i think there's probably
echoes of the wyoming bill that have
been baked into the ucc
uh but it's not you know one for one
okay uh representative hebert
um again um trade association i heard
the word trade association somewhere
into the mic please
uh
one of the speakers came up and
mentioned he was a member of a trade
association
and that association is what
that trade association is american
bankers association american bankers the
aba aba so the aba is
uh on board with cryptocurrency so they
they have we've spoken with our god
parts
sorry sorry
our our counterparts have spoken um
we've we've talked to our counterparts
down at the aba and um they've they've
been following this and they are okay
with this
okay with this so
so the the aba is
you're not the aba or new hampshire
bankers association you're the new
hampshire bankers association we have a
banker's association that's not in favor
of this so i'm just trying to i'm just
remembering
i'm just trying to get the party
straight
the original bill we had concerns with
um this is a replace hall the
representative hunt and representative
amman are talking about
um
the amendment so we are at this point we
are okay with the changes are you going
to send out a correcting one though
because we've got this in our notes
um if you could send out a correcting
uh paper that would be helpful for us as
we're reviewing all of this yeah we'd be
happy to okay thank you you're welcome
okay
rich yeah go ahead yes thank you um
since there are uh
fiscal notes uh on the bills we're
considering
do does our committee need to
try to appropriate the money or would
that go that would go when it goes on
that's the reason why the bills are
early yes some committees you know some
they will they would put the you know
the appropriation line item in that
other ones they just wait till it gets
to finance and let them do it
so
they're supposed to be better at
negotiating the price
the compensation than we are but
okay chris what do you got final uh
request
first you were against it
first you were against it now you're for
it
i would like to at some point understand
why you changed
in some detail
yes please
actually you know what why don't you
guys just take a seat over here
and that way you don't have to move
again
yeah
um so christy merrill new hampshire
bankers association you are correct we
originally opposed the legislation as it
was written
um this is really a very different
approach i think is accomplishing what
the sponsor is looking to do
and so because of you know part of our
opposition was because we supported the
ucc framework and the and the
the format of the uniform law commission
which is
to take a look and have it it's a vetted
process that the states can adopt um
article 12 that deals with these issues
has gone through that
and so for new hampshire to be an early
adopter
we feel like is a better approach than
the underlying bill that was written so
this is really a different
approach
that we are more comfortable with
okay thank you but we still haven't seen
the amendment either
you haven't told me why you changed your
mind
it's a better approach
well and
because it originally it was happening
outside of the ucc and that was part of
our concern is because
the the laws that new hampshire has
adopted is important to banks and how
they do business across state lines so
that's why we that's why we oppose the
bill
this is going through the ucc process
to make
changes so we believe that banks can
continue to do business
across state lines with those same
certainties
that being said we have not seen the
amendment but so far we are more
comfortable with this approach
further question
further question the speedy uh
concept
of a bank
is relatively new from my understanding
um that is house bill 1504 which is
separate from this discussion they are
related topics right but that is a
separate
situation so is the speedy uh
banking concept
now enclosed in
no we're going to kill speedy
no after we kill speedy is it going to
pop up could be 1702
representative i don't know that i would
characterize it as popping up i think
some of the concepts that are addressed
in article 12 are sort of foundational
to working with crypto and bitcoin and
working in this space and so i think
some of those foundational topics are
addressed through
article 12.
as we said before we oppose a new
creation of a new charter a new banking
division we were opposed to that and so
that conceivably if that legislation
dies would go away
but i think addresses some of the
underlying fundamental issues
if that makes sense
we didn't want to create a new division
we want every bank anybody who's you
know run is can conform can this way
this way your
your private wealth trust department
whatever whoever has your your money can
actually have crypto in its portfolio
for you
we didn't want a separate division
and that's had the outrageous fiscal
note so that that's
frankly it was dead on arrival
yes thank you mr chair um so we can
count on your staying at the table with
yes they're not moving from right there
okay
you know so that you'll be here next
week or whenever how long this takes us
to
to get through because it's um you know
we're a bunch of volunteers you're the
professionals so we need your guidance
um and as well as the banking department
certainly to help us with
you know feeling comfortable
um which is great thank you
okay
yes
i have a question about the amendment
that's being drafted that's over 100 uh
a 100 pages
where is that information coming from
and
do you know what is in the amendment
i have not read 112 pages of it um there
have been some summaries provided that
we've looked at including this
powerpoint that then riot had you know
sort of offered to share which i think
would be helpful um the language is is a
byproduct of the uniform law commission
so that is where the language is coming
from okay thanks we are not reinventing
the wheel that's the whole point okay
yeah amelia
just everybody know this is our our bank
commissioner
for the moment
[Laughter]
so i would also say just for the record
that while the pdf that we gave to ols
was 110 pages there was a lot of
commentary in there um which will not
become law and it's very explanatory and
um you know to the extent you get an
amendment that doesn't have that
commentary and it may be helpful to go
and look at the commentary because it
may help answer some of the questions
that that i'm hearing that's a good idea
why why it's doing what it's doing um
certainly better than me because i'm not
the ucc expert um
so i think that might that might help
you answer some questions i'm happy to
send that to whoever i think a number of
you have it already but to the extent
some that would help
yeah i think that you know all of us
would want to would want to see that and
preferably
sent to us in hard copy so that we
aren't printing it off at home at 110
pages
whoa we
um i i would think you would just read
it online
i mean do you really want to you really
want to have
staff here print all those pages and
mail them out to everything
old-fashioned when it comes to trying to
read it all online
um
i i i i
you you can ask i will give you
permission to ask carrie to print print
you want okay just individually that'd
be fine
but i don't want to send that out to
everybody
have you have you read the liquor the
liquor report did you read that yet
i mean come on guys
i am a fiscal conservative you know
i used to say we didn't want to kill
trees but but uh
gene chandler used to tell me no we do
want to kill trees that's our luck
that's our beaver mill industry we do
want to kill trees
yeah
if
we were to not
have
if we were not discussing 1502 the ucc
or the ulc will will release the
language of the ucc chapter 12
at some point in the future and we would
have to have a discussion of whether or
not to adopt that those that anyway
would does the legislature
adopt that length choose to adopt that
language does the banking department say
we're going to adopt that language who
makes the determination that we're going
to we do
it's a legislation okay so so at some
point in time we have to deal with this
new chapter 12. it's either now or it's
later
so what would happen is whatever
differences that occurs when the final
edition goes out
we can then put in a separate bill at
that time
to bring it in line if we adopt the
language as they presently have drafted
correct
anything different between now and when
they release the final final version you
would have to come in as a separate bill
you have to come in a separate
legislation and we would have to vote on
okay but if we adopt the language now
going replacing whatever's in 1502 now
with whatever that language is in draft
form correct
that at least
puts us a step ahead to be able to begin
to act on
this new space i'm going to use new
language now to begin working in that
new space of crypto technology correct
and we would be the first in the country
to be doing that thus inviting
new
innovation into the state
maybe expanding our tax base cutting
down new trees to build new homes
whatever that means maybe securities can
get some uh
collect yeah or something what do we how
much do we charge for when people do
those uh
the statements and the uh
those proxies that
not proxies they're uh
the other fun
yes
just while everyone's at the table here
um there was discussion about a separate
issue a discussion about creating a
study commission is there is there still
an appetite for that
or should we set that aside just
there was a study commission i think
from 2015 to 20
i don't know 2019 maybe you know well
you don't need no commission
we don't need it so no no i mean we got
us okay we don't need the commission
where else all right
that was part of the discussion i'm just
closing the loop
uh would you believe
back when i took business law at new
hampshire college
the ucc
was required reading
for any business law
student
and it there's some things that are
interesting
and some things that will lull you to
sleep
would you believe
okay
yes chris
one of the questions i want to answer
is whose full faith and credit is behind
this law
full faith and credit
this could be a you know an issue if
we're going to be the first through the
door
make sure somebody doesn't slam it
behind us
but the
whos full faith and credit is
responsible
for the consequences of this law
that should be a question i think for
the commissioner
i don't know
do you have an answer for that one
difficulty identifying who's behind it i
don't know if i can answer that question
i think he's getting it he's always
worried that
this blockchain technology is used by
criminal elements no it is used by
criminal elements and so therefore who
is it at any point in time that is the
state of new hampshire
because it has a statute or could we get
dragged into this criminal activity
is that your question chris well who's
on the hook if if something untoward
might happen i mean okay god knows it's
never happened before
so so the ucc governs how people like
interact for business purposes
microphone sorry sorry have a seat okay
you get your seat now i just keep
sliding forward so i might as well sit
here um
so the ucc governs how entities transact
business
um and this article 12 really just
um
acknowledges the existence of
bitcoin and cryptocurrency and those
types of transactions and makes a
uniform law that governs how
businesses can basically interact how
banks can interact with it how you how
like how you can transact business sort
of in a uniform way using it
so i think it's not
i mean you're asking more of a big scale
policy question about cryptocurrency
whereas i think this is just and and
certainly the securities folks maybe
could had would have a better because
they're really the experts on the ucc
they might have a better way to describe
what the ucc does but it really governs
how people enter how business entities
interact with each other using certain
um
like negotiable instruments like checks
and
security interests and how they perfect
security interests and property um so
it's really like almost like a technical
manual
um whereas like i think you're asking
more of a big picture policy question
about cryptocurrency that
is not i mean
that that's kind of the extent of my
knowledge but i don't know if that kind
of helps understand what
you're trying to accomplish with the ucc
it's a very narrow kind of business
transaction governing law
okay i know who the full faith and
credit is behind the dollar it's it's
the federal reserve and the
uh national economy
and and the u.s congress
i do not
uh but what does that
mean to you because what does that mean
that's behind it in other words that
that well if we bailed out wall street
three times
in my in my lifetime so
that's what it means okay so those
bailouts were not cryptocurrency is in
my mind i could be mistaken right uh is
in my mind
uh going to
[Music]
is trying to establish itself as a
legitimate
currency
like the dollar
like the eu
and and it's having a tremendous amount
of
success apparently there is a it's not
currency
i beg to differ
if it looks like a duck
it's a duck
so uh
um
this is what the currency is baby this
currency was developed
to launder money
money oh my god no not not not rocks not
wood
all right not this
i hear you i hear chris that's your
personal opinion no that's the history
okay
so anyway yeah
you really want to respond to that keys
just briefly okay
so so cash money is also used in a lot
of illegal transactions it doesn't mean
that we don't use cash right so just
because criminals use cars and shoes and
the internet doesn't mean that all those
things are bad right so you
don't fall into the trap of painting
technology as evil just because
sometimes people use it for bad deeds
number one um
so the full faith and credit you talked
about the bailouts right so
it's i can go into this all day and i
won't but
the the genesis of bitcoin was to to
stop bailouts because if you remember
the occupy wall street movement people
were upset
that the banks got bailouts and in this
you know these digital assets which are
really more property than than currency
there is no bailout that's the whole
point like there's no central authority
that can bail out their friends and
leave behind the little people that's
one of the
you know the appeals of it but you have
to think of it more like gold than the
dollar because it's designed to be a
digital form of gold
in its properties and in its features
what people how people value it in their
minds is a whole different thing right
so
um but you have to think of it more like
gold than it's it's more of a an asset a
piece of property than a currency yeah
no i'm familiar with the gold so here's
the new expression it's a consumable
token
that sounds pretty and shiny and i'm
sure people are really excited well
maybe it's like the quarter before they
stop putting the car copper inside it
back when it was actual gold
okay any more questions all right
so
don't move you guys stay right where you
are
so we know where we are and and uh so
now securities you want to come up here
take
theoretically there's this is kind of a
moving
thing because we're not going to pass
anything today
okay we're just getting warmed up to
everything
and you will absolutely by the time
you're done you'll be able to explain
all of this
so that when members of your caucus says
what the hell did you guys do
you should be able to you should be able
to explain it
and understand what we're doing here
okay
so we started out with that the key
element that 1504
was the one that says okay you you have
these different divisions in banking and
they had that you know five million
dollar you know fiscal note whatever so
that is we're not going to pass that
that's not going to happen
instead we're taking
what's the structure in our statutes
that regulate
um business transactions
and that's what the ucc is it's really
business transaction that's what the
statute is about okay and how it's
handled so
obviously for us in new hampshire we
have two regulatory authorities that are
affected by the ucc statute and that's
banking
and securities
so securities is 1503.
okay gentlemen
good afternoon mr chair uh barry glennon
uh and kevin moakman with the bureau of
securities regulation um
mr chair we we've had the opportunity to
review um the uh proposed language and
uh we did a bit of a reorganization of
some of the language and communicated
that uh to representative ammon
and i believe that we have a
workable amendment i believe i can't
speak for representative ammon but i
believe he
considered this considers this to be
acceptable
attorney mulkan will speak to some of
the specifics of of the changes and
there may be one minor change to the
actual amendment just looking at the
amendment uh yes i realized the first
edition maybe just this there may be
some slight uh change to that so okay
thank you
um so
essentially what we've done is we have
uh tried to fit this into the the format
of our law 421b
um one of the issues that that we saw
was that
by
accepting uh
the tokens from the definition
of a security it kind of raised the
question well we would then really kind
of have no enforcement power at all uh
and it called for fraud authority
because we're not dealing with the
security so what we proposed then was to
change us around
so that instead of saying it's not a
security saying that transactions and
these securities are exempt
from the registration requirements
uh and also that uh people who
participate in this are exempt from
being registered as broker dealers
so essentially that's what we've done
now the one thing i think
barry was referring to this
in section one of the amendment i'm
looking at it
um
and i think i might have
misunderstanding
because the language in the original
bill came from the solicitor's
definition in our statute my
understanding is that the uh
what they were trying to do at that time
was to create an exception
for the blockchain tokens
from uh this definition of securities
um i believe what we want to do is
in a future amendment is take out that
whole section one because it doesn't
apply
uh and again we would not
define securities in such a way to
exclude
blockchain tokens we would instead
create a
transactional exemption
which means they don't have to register
the securities
another issue was defining an issue
where to exclude
people who deal in these tokens
again
to exclude them from broker-dealer
requirements that sort of thing
there already is an exclusion from the
definition of brokered dealer for
issuers so
uh
it in essence it doesn't serve any
purpose and it could actually raise
questions about our authority if there
is fraud which again is kind of carved
out
in the original bill
um
see and when we say are carved out we're
actually that we retain authority in the
event of any kind of fraudulent conduct
right as opposed to eliminating it
right
um
one of the things that we we did add and
uh again we don't want
uh consumers of these tokens to be under
the impression that because a notice
filing is made for uh with us that in
some way these are registered
because really it's just a notice filing
to say this is what we're doing here's
information about us
we don't have to go through any approval
process or anything like that so we
wanted to make sure
that when um
that notice is filed that that notice
will include a statement that in any
advertising on the internet and so forth
that it be made clear that they're not
registered
uh secure as securities with the state
of new hampshire
and uh then
the other uh
major change not a major change there
really wasn't any major changes
was uh to take out the requirement for
electronic filings
uh we wanted that to be clear because we
don't currently have a process for
receiving those types of filings
so we just took that out so we can
receive by email we can receive hard
copies
i'm sure that's probably not going to be
a favorite way of doing it with
cryptocurrency and uh
blockchain token people but um but we
can take them by email and then get them
into our
our filing system our database
so i
think essentially that's it i don't know
if you wanted me to go through step by
step in the amendment but
um
i think i can point out
that we have defined
open blockchain token we've taken it out
of the proposed news section the first
bill and put it into our definitional
section so it's defined there
language is taken direct from the
original bill
uh so that's section
two
section three again is the exempt
transaction
uh the exemption for uh exempt
transactions where that was added
uh so again
uh the transactions
uh are not going to be required to be
registered as securities
which um was the intent to begin with
um
section three i'm sorry yeah section
three well i just did that uh excuse me
section four
um
is the broker dealer exemption and again
took the language that was in the
original bill
and put it
where it seemed most appropriate in the
brokered dealer section to
explicitly create an exception from the
registration requirement
so again it it uh it was more matter of
reorganization
than anything uh to make sure
that if there is fraudulent securities
conduct
that we still have the authority to go
after that but we would have no
authority
in terms of registering
registering the tokens as securities or
registering uh people who do the
transactions or facilitators as broker
dealers
so
chris to answer your question
the key element here is
secure we under our consumer protection
statutes 358a we have exemptions
and our exemptions is securities
by
passing this legislation with that
saying is that they're unregulated by
securities that means
their regulator is the attorney
general's office
okay and you
can sue them
for triple damages
if you were harmed
but that you wouldn't call them
you would call your favorite trial
lawyer
did i not answer your question well what
is the purpose of registration of a
search security of all our securities um
what is the purpose of registration
registration
so uh well that's just a good that's not
why why do we have a securities division
[Laughter]
well it does go back to 1933 with the
well actually it goes back further than
that uh but it it's basically a process
of initial review
where we get to look
at an offering and say
you know does it have particular
information because it's really all
about disclosure and so
we go through to make sure
that they are making proper disclosures
of information that an investor would
want to know
um
in making a decision about investing
because these are these aren't
registered right so these would be
outside of that
view
yeah only in the case of fraud if there
was fraud and if it was determined to be
a security
then we could take action as as
representative hunt said
um
otherwise basically you're dealing with
the attorney general's office under the
consumer
protection division
so that the law
so the current law in new hampshire now
if you felt you were
hurt or fraud by
some blockchain transaction
you do not call the banking department
you do not call securities
all you can do is call the attorney
general or your favorite trial lawyer
yeah i have so many questions we'll be
here all day so
i'm just okay we'll move along then very
fishy
revenant bartlett thank you mr sheriff
so um i've just got a question just in
the beginning of your testimony you said
that there were a couple of things that
had to be corrected in this amendment
and i missed them yeah one thing which
was section one
um
which was a misinterpretation of what
was trying to be accomplished uh section
one deals with solicitors which really
has nothing to do with uh
blockchain tokens
um so will this be deleted that can be
deleted so all of section one can be
deleted yes okay yeah
so we'll get a new we'll get a new
amendment all right we'll have a new one
drawn up momentarily thank you sorry
but i don't explain we're not going to
execute anything today so you don't have
to we're not going to exactly anything
today
okay
yes chris oh thank you uh chairman i
assume and please correct me if i'm
wrong
that the broker-dealer community
likes the fact that this is not a
security
no one's asked them
there's been some real hesitation on on
the part of the broker-dealer community
to engage in this because they have
concerns perhaps you know issues that
representative herbert has raised you
know face if a broker dealer is engaged
in a certain type of activity then
they're liable if they offer a certain
product on their platform they're
responsible even though they may be just
the trading entity for the transaction
uh they may carry some liability a
customer could come to them and say well
your representative sold this to me
uh therefore you're responsible so
there's been some hesitation there but
there are also some that are very
progressive uh from our standpoint where
they want to engage in this but uh it's
not exclusively offered through or nor
is it required to be offered through a
broken dealer well i just uh present
questions two quick follow-ups uh years
ago uh index annuities the
broker-dealers did not want this to be
security and finally the sec went along
with that right and so i'm looking at
that similar but
i read recently that the federal uh sec
is still looking to try to find a way to
make this a security is that correct
that is correct they're they're looking
at it uh and it's been a long time that
that they've been looking at it but uh
you know we're essentially uh
representative dealing with the
legislation that's being proposed so and
trying to make it you know fit with the
statute thank you very much go ahead
keith
yeah so to speak to the sec issue um
so digital tokens can be
they can come in lots of different forms
uh some of them can be issued by a
central company
as part of like an equity offering and
that would that would be classified as a
security i think everybody would agree
on that
but the sec is reluctant
has been reluctant to classify
something like bitcoin
as a security because there's no central
company behind it there wasn't it like
there wasn't an initial offering it just
grew organically on the internet so
things come in different forms when
we're talking about digital tokens
think of like a chuck e cheese token
where you put it into the machine and it
only works at chuck e cheese right
that's a token this is this can be like
a digital form of a token there's like
there's a concept in the bill it talks
about a consumptive
purpose to the token so consumptive
would mean that you use the token to
facilitate some kind of computer
network some kind of activity on the
computer network and an example would be
if youtube had uh a consumptive token
attached to its offering you would put
the token in on your computer to watch a
video and you'd consume that that token
so the consumptive
purpose is a key portion of this bill
and if it's consumptive then it's not a
it's not wouldn't be considered a
security if that makes sense
go ahead rich
yes i'd like to ask if there's a
possibility that
something that the federal government
might do
subsequently would put would
over could possibly override this if
they decided that there that this should
be considered
uh
uh a security because people might
invest in it and hold it until it's
worth more and then sell it uh that it
uh i mean could that happen down the
line and if it did
what would that do to our law
it's already happening well
representative there is always the issue
of preemption
and uh that they could uh
decide that they want to occupy you know
this space as they may say
uh where this the sec is not there yet
um you know new hampshire is is pretty
much out front here um you know with
this carve out um but anything's
possible i've learned over the years
and i suspect it could be something that
might be hashed out in court as well so
but the key thing is is that
nothing's really changed in the sense
that we already in new hampshire have
made the decision that we weren't going
to regulate this that that
you know that you're staying out of it
and all we're doing is repeating that in
the statute with these with this
paragraphs
so it's not a beanie baby anymore
so um
basically
you you're not handling that i mean
you're out of this the securities you
don't want it to be you don't want to
have anything to do with it except when
you're notified of something well there
would be a notice filing uh
with the state and the expectation is
attorney mokokun mentioned that to be
some form of disclosure that it's not
regulated or approved by the state
however in the event in the course of
let's say
the distribution of these tokens that
somehow it turns into somebody starts to
promote it as an investment for example
that you know because a lot of people do
buy frankly they do buy you on
speculation that the cost is going to
increase
but if somebody was out there promoting
this as an investment you know then
uh and they they did so and it was
fraudulent then uh the bureau would be
able to step in and so um
whenever um there's uh bitcoin
transactions tokens
um
you get notified no you do not not at
this point no this would only be if
there was somebody actively
marketing it as an investment
opportunity how would they know that
uh we would not uh out at the front end
uh know that it was being marketed
somebody dropped a dime on them
somebody what dropped a dime someone
said hey did you know these people are
doing this then they they would step in
it's going to be regulated but it's
really not going to be regulated
only if there's fraudulent conduct that
we determined that they were offering it
as an investment and that it was that
the offering was fraudulent
otherwise
it is not subject to
any registration excuse me registration
or regulation
goes back to even actually when you use
frm is an example
okay and that is
that
they were you know was that when the
accusations security should have done
something about it okay would been is
how was it promoted how was it marketed
you know as an investment opportunity
then they would be it was you know
obviously
then the securities would have had to
step in and just you know review
what they had the filings and there
there was no filings right they wouldn't
they never filed anything
so but that yes they are our watchdog
if you
um feel like somebody is trying to sell
you you know
telling you something as though they
were a broker and they're saying oh i
got this great company you need to
invest in
these are the people you would call
right and for the banking industry same
thing it's being regulated but it's not
or it's not being regulated or
uh will you with the banking industry
well your
bank commissioner is right there to your
right
oh yeah yeah so okay
sorry
um
so
you will be regulating it or not
no
okay
sorry so the bill is about regulation
but it sounds like there's not going to
be right now we have to remember what's
the law in new hampshire there is no
regulation whatsoever and the banking
department has if you were to go on to
their web page they will make it clear
to you that they are not regulating
these transactions whatsoever right well
so
the only time we at banking get involved
is if you have a money transmitter like
wes think western union although i don't
think they do any of this but an entity
like western union that takes
takes your cryptocurrency and
gives somebody else cash
fiat currency
that's the only time we regulate
an entity that
does the serve transactional work now
theoretically one of our trust companies
under current law could custody
could hold crypto in custody
um so there are some limited
circumstances but
in terms of like
i want to go pay some i i
have some cryptocurrency that i own and
i want to go
buy a beer down the street you know at
the bar or what you know whatever you
want to do with your cryptocurrency that
transaction would not be regulated with
us and i think that's analogous to what
these folks are saying but i don't want
to speak
you okay all right
representative herbert so
get the mic close
thank you emilia
so i bought myself a 50 000
bitcoin
and uh then i decided well
shoot i you know
i'm nervous about it because it just
went
you know it looks like it could be kind
of sketchy so
i go into my bank and i give them the
bitcoin and i say uh
i'd like to have my
50 000
please because that's the price on the
market
and uh and and the teller will say
well no problem
and
i'll have fifty thousand dollars in my
uh checking account or savings account
or whatever account and and the bank
will have me in possession chris you
really gotta close the mic and the bank
will be in possession of a 50
a a
bitcoin that has whatever the value was
i i don't understand it i mean so amelia
i guess maybe why don't you come up take
a seat up here
so the answer is no chris
no you won't get the cash
okay
so you're saying
i just want to make sure i understand
you you're saying somebody walk you buy
a bit you have a bitcoin in your
possession or a fraction of wine and i
paid dollars for it that you paid
dollars for and you want to go and do
like a currency exchange at a bank you
want to turn it back to dollars
yeah i don't think there's any banks
that do that to my knowledge so i'm not
sure
because they would
paypal
paypal does it
paypal paypal paypal will do it for you
yeah that's what mr ma went to jail for
in china
right who yeah there's a guy in china
that was super billionaire
he's he wanted to start a paypal and
china didn't like it anyway
the point is
i can't give him that doesn't do that
i'm trying to doesn't do i'm trying to
figure out how the transactions happen
we don't we don't regulate ex people
that just exchange it
so you wanna you have crypto you wanna
trade it in for dollars we don't touch
that transaction that's like that's a
pure exchange
if you wanted to transmit that to
somebody else
and there was cash involved so you
wanted to you want to
you wanted to get rid of your get rid of
your crypt i can't even think of i'm
sorry
i'm not sure i'm following all the token
your token yeah you want you want to
come in with your say you want to pay
chairman hunt
for something
or
i'm trying to provide an example that
would be regulated so you have crypto
you want to pay somebody for something
using like for example like an entity
like paypal but chairman hunt says i
only want cash
the the end paypal in that i'm not even
sure they do this but they actually they
do they do this okay i don't know each
one's business model we regulate paypal
they're licensed with us
so we would examine them to make sure
that transaction was conducted securely
and appropriately exactly so the only
time they would get involved is if they
say there was something wrong with the
transaction
and you thought it was paypal who
screwed up and you filed a complaint
with you would file a complaint with
them we also examined them and you
they would examine it so
but
paypal is not a bank
right that is correct
so
they're just a money transfer full faith
and credit behind this transaction is
paypal
okay
you're looking for full faith but there
is no foreign did you understand the
expression the full faith is is that you
that that piece of paper that tender
you the faith is that you that the
united states stands behind that it
really is worth a dollar
right okay even though the federal
reserve stands behind the dollar right
but the federal reserve the full faith
is that
the federal reserve was created by the
united states government right
chris
oh sorry
thank you mr chair um i've got a
question for the commissioner and by the
way congratulations
i know you've been sworn in as the new
banking commissioner which is wonderful
because we spent a lot of time together
i've got a question because bitcoin can
also be property
can it be real estate
and does that change anything
and that might be for representative
amman yeah i so i do know that what i
would say is that i know blockchain
technology itself can be used for a lot
of different purposes that are somewhat
outside the scope of this discussion and
outside of our regulatory jurisdiction
okay people use the the ledger
technology to do
tons
potentially do lots and lots of
different things and that's very
different than like
kind of this exchange of funds concept
that we're talking about um but perhaps
representative amendment yeah go ahead
keith
yeah that was a good explanation yeah so
um
i think mostly we're talking about
things that are happening in the virtual
space right so these tokens you
i think i mentioned in my earlier
testimony that it has to do with proving
ownership that's really like this one of
the core concepts of this and we're
proving ownership about digital tokens
whether it's bitcoin or some other
token that's used for some specific
purpose
but the idea of tying the proof of
ownership to the physical world
maybe a piece of property or a car or
something
i think that's coming in in the not too
distant future but we're not quite there
yet but you could imagine instead of
registering your deed with
uh you know your town clerk that you
register it on a state-approved ledger
system and that proves your ownership
and maybe as part of that there's a
smart contract where there's a transfer
tax of you know one percent or whatever
it is and every time a piece of property
changes hand the states the state gets
that one percent i mean you could you
could definitely do that in uh
you know in the blockchain ledger space
but i think right now we're just talking
about the virtual world and not
necessarily the physical world now
another question i got is um one of the
um
people that that testified before our
committee last week was lisa tripp and
she's a nurse practitioner in portsmouth
and she gave me a call at home
and told me how terribly important it
was to pass
some of this legislation so that her
patients
can pay in bitcoin
would her transactions be
affecting
any of the banking department or is that
strictly a private transaction
so if i remember her testimony correctly
she referenced using coinbase coinbase
is regulated by us they have a license
to conduct money transmission um and
they do
interact with cryptocurrency as well as
fiat currency
so they're already licensed by us to do
exactly what she described okay so the
advantage
for her
clients would be because they don't use
a bank
but they are still protected by the
banking department is that correct i i
don't remember her testimony in that
level of detail i i
i apologize i don't want to speak to it
but to the extent she was discussing
interacting with coinbase coinbase is
regulated by us thank you yeah
everybody comfortable
i still have a question about
bitcoin i mean this bill you want this
to be regulated but yet it doesn't seem
like
it's going to be regulated but
they'll be
everybody in this room will be notified
the word regulation is maybe where you
have to understand what we're trying to
where we're going with it
because it's really an industry that's
just growing and changing right okay
and so in terms of regulating like we
regulate securities or banking
no we we really don't want that we
we want it to be on its own but so what
we're trying to do with the ucc statute
is that it recognizes its existence
and that it is a business transaction
that occurs
between
individuals it's a business transaction
and this sets up the framework to allow
those transactions to occur
for all kinds of purposes the regulator
is the attorney general's office
or your favorite trial lawyer
okay the triple damages under the
consumer protection act because at the
end of the day
these departments are not regulating
them like we regulate
uh banking and securities
all right
and
much that i'm dare to say it is there
anybody in the audience who has anything
else they would like to add or share or
become aware of otherwise
we'll take this up again next wednesday
at 11 a.m
yep
next wednesday is going to be
uh
just
we're gonna
in the morning we have we're not gonna
have a big conversation uh next
wednesday it'll be between the members
of the committee the subcommittee
subcommittee and the world
right but having said that at 1 15 on
wednesday
we will have an exact session
and if we don't then we have to get
eight bills
exact
and uh and i scheduled 115 on thursday
the follow-up if we don't get exec but
we otherwise thursday we will have
hearing we're having hearings
but
we hope next thursday we won't have
exactly anything that we'll just do
subcommittee so hoping we'll get take
on wednesday morning we'll
have
the language we got working with and
that wednesday at 1 15 we would vote on
the bill
all these bills
okay
thank you very much
all right moving right along
prohibiting the sale of products
containing intentionally added pfes do
we is the sponsor here
mr chair he's not here but i've been
talking to him because i'm very
interested in this bill he's working so
he wasn't able to come today okay um and
he didn't get information from maine
either you know i've been asking for you
know documentation about the bill that
was passed in maine and he didn't he
didn't forward it to me so
you know i don't know
is there someone from the department of
environmental services here he's sitting
right behind you
so at any rate uh at this
oh he's yours he's one of yours okay
these masks you know i never know who
everybody is
so they were here before and they
basically said that this you know this
is a bear
and and it's a nightmare because really
the problem is not you know in terms of
originally we were thinking about
drinking water but we solved that
problem in this committee last year but
this is the issue of whatever is made
with pfas and then ends up in the uh in
in the dump and therefore poisons the
water so i i think at this point the
best thing for us to do with this bill
is just to interim study this bill yeah
i i i thought um
i was involved with the gmo
labeling and i i thought perhaps we
could
address some of these issues through
labeling the products that have pfas and
pfoas
similar to you know how we now label uh
gmos
oh glad you brought that up um actually
that legislation never did pass okay and
but that um it was a federal
federal issue
okay so it's it's really a federal issue
i mean if we wanted these products to be
labeled pf
but i think that i think the one thing
that that amazed me because i kept
wondering why where this all coming from
was that the all of a sudden
it seems like everything is made with
pfas
so i don't know how mane is going to
solve that problem but uh they probably
ended up with just with disclosure but
again
you know it seemed what it sounds like
the upshot is is that if a you have to
know that it has pfas and b is you got
to treat it like mercury
you know you got to you know bring it to
the special special facilities to have
it done taking care of
yes chris
um so if we wanted to
close to the mic
if we wanted to uh
prohibit uh dumping pfas uh
material into our landfills
if that was a goal of the legislation
would that come in under the interim
study uh
the interim study is to aid i think most
importantly is to follow what happened
happening in maine and how they're how
they're handling their statute
but at the end of the day yeah you're
you've got to treat the stuff like
asbestos or mercury
and how do we you know how do we deal
you know deal with i mean i
i know i always hear about these sites
to where people are going in and
removing the asbestos but where are they
taking that asbestos uh what is the
proper handling i
i'm that's
not in my
prayer
that's not my committee our committee
and another problem with this
bill is there's a there's a lot of pfas
coming in from other states because uh
companies waste management companies are
you know filling up our landfills uh 50
or 60 percent of our landfills is now
coming from out of state and
if they don't have any regulation then
we will still be getting pfoas in our
landfills because of you know the
industry those agreements that allow
them to deliver their garbage to us
so okay is it everybody comfortable with
interim studying with
be fast so at least we can keep an eye
on it and see what's happening there
okay great now we're on schedule
okay prohibiting banks or businesses
from using social credit scores so uh we
have an amendment as is people got
copies of the amendment
um the one thing i would say i would
change in the amendment
is um it left the
section one the preamble
and
i would
i'm going to have the amendment drawn up
to remove that
from the bill
and the other question that many people
are asking is why did i remove the
penalties that were in the original bill
and the reason being is that both these
statutes actually have penalties already
in them so the banking department
already has the power of restitution
and
ability to pull the license of a
facility
and
and the um the second section which
which is actually third section in here
the second with in when we printed is
the consumer protection act and in the
consumer protection act um there is
penalties and as i stated earlier the
penalties are
triple damages
and or if you you know and
you have the right a private action so
you don't necessarily have the attorney
general will take on the case but
um you can certainly hire a lawyer and
sue sue whoever
committed that crime
yes representative bartlett thank you mr
chair so just to be clear the
declaration of purpose would be deleted
is that correct correct um and that it
never is part of the law anyway
that's the that's one of the reasons i
delete that okay yeah and then um so
then the new sub paragraph two
is where this amendment starts up but
this amendment is still going to be
amended again is that correct it'll say
instead of saying amend the bill by
replacing after section one they'll say
amend the bill
uh by re uh
after the title
i believe that's the way they say it
okay
have we got the amendment in front of me
do i have it did you have it yes it was
distributed last night you should have
printed it off
yeah there's a pile here if you like one
chris if you want one
careful don't trip
yeah oh it is okay i know i'm that's a
real trip hazard
good for you
well every time i see somebody go near
it i'm afraid they're gonna trip on it
okay here's the scoop
so mr chair yep so this um
really is just saying that i i have this
i have was
um
so this is just saying that it's
prohibiting discrimination
yeah discrimination correct okay i don't
have a i don't have an issue with that
okay
okay you have a question
thank you mr chair um just thinking
through the amendment um
page two line one
uh just talks about property or
investments already owned wouldn't would
that go towards
someone's credit worthiness and would
that
like excluding that from consideration
would that be uh an issue just
just thinking out loud
which uh
[Music]
i'll ask again so page two line one it
says it's uh
a bank can't discriminate against or
pose a precondition based on and then
line one page two property investments
already owned and i think that might
speak to credit worthiness and maybe i'm
just misunderstanding it crit in order
to if you already have a
banking relationship
you already have a loan
they can't cancel the loan
based on these
criteria
okay
so this doesn't go to credit worthiness
uh that's true it wouldn't we've just by
taking out the penalties we would remove
it needing to go to a second committee
but i'm treating us with full steam
ahead and
represent abel
yes
thank you um
so if an individual
believed that he or she
were a victim of this kind of
discrimination
uh
they would go to court and
i mean what what would be what would be
the uh and then have to prove right so
if if they're if it was uh a bank
then they would uh bring the complaint
to the banking department
and the banking department will
they don't really have a hearing's
officer i'm not sure how they would
handle
how to handle it but they would you know
investigate to you know talk to the bank
and get the bank to
tell us you know would make come clean i
would be very surprised that any bank
would be foolish enough to
cancel somebody over any of these things
anyways
but you know the person had make the in
assuming that person if let's say the
second section which would be a business
if a business was discriminating
the case on this and
that you would have to have some you
know you would go
this is that would you would take to
court or call up the attorney general's
office
represent below
yeah um we had testimony uh last week by
someone from the heartland institute
and um i believe the legislation is
pretty much coming from the heartland
institute
and
i have a problem because it seems like
this is
censorship i mean heartland has always
been public about its ultimate goals to
keep global warming alarmists from
winning the public debate
so it sounds like
this is targeting
um and the funders of heartland are also
the big you know companies that ag big
ag companies that monsantos and
i read up all about
heartland institute so it sounds like
they're really pushing their agenda and
it seems like they're going to be
censoring
um where
you know
in their favor so that
really they don't want people thinking
that you know global warming is real
so i i would hope and and i know jeff
would like to add in but i would hope
that
the way that you know my name is at the
top of this page here you know this
amendment that i've you know been
working on is that i have taken away
anybody else's ownership of why this
bill is in front of us other than i want
to ensure that we don't have
discrimination
and and that
whether it's true or not and
discriminating someone because of their
behavior and turn and
particularly their politics
and saying no i'm not going to do
business with you because you are a
climate denialist
um i think is just wrong that you know
that's
uh i don't think they any any business
or financial institution or in business
either one should not be telling someone
i'm not going to do business with you
because you're a climate denialist no
but the the the opposite end people that
you know
understand that you know there is
climate change and there is global
warming i mean are you protecting
those that side as well sure
uh well
in terms of if those people are going to
uh assert their position
by taking it out on someone else's
business livelihood
and i would say no i don't agree with
them
you want to add to that jeff all i was
going to say is
i wrote this
not the heartland institute
just so i i don't i don't know what
their agenda is and i don't really care
what their agenda is the point is
that
discrimination on either side
so
your employer
pays your paycheck and let's say it's
directly deposited to a bank
all right
suddenly this bank says
we don't like your politics
so we are not going to accept
not only your businesses
transactions we're not going to process
your credit cards we're not going to
honor your checks we're not going to
receive your deposits and all of your
employees whose paychecks are deposited
at that bank we're not going to accept
those anymore either because we don't
like your politics we don't i don't know
who's that is whatever side that is you
can say hey but i i believe in climate
change
and they the bank says well we don't
but i don't believe in climate change
the bank says well we do it's both sides
you're covered either way
your political party your affiliation it
doesn't matter you and i are both we're
on opposite sides on most issues but on
this we're both protected
because it happens
uh yes thank you uh mr chairman but
if we if i look at the
uh testimony from uh from last week
michael vose uh he presents a totally
different uh perspective
he's saying that this uh
this discrimination is clearly to
prevent
the proliferation of fossil fuels this
is part of a
marx marxist plot
of resetting the global economy and all
that so are you telling me that this is
not what this particular
thing
amendment says is that correct
this bill
would prevent
a bank or an investment firm a financial
institution
from targeting
a fossil fuel industry
and saying we are cutting you off
because
we disagree with your
we've had a long-standing relationship
with you now we're just cutting you off
because we disagree with your politics
well that's not what esg says but this
is not esg
all right so that's the way it was
presented last week secondly that's why
we changed the wording
if you look at uh
under amendment under two line
seven
or actually line six
uh a bank whatever shall not
discriminate against pose as a
precondition advocate for causes adverse
treatment of any person business
organization etc
and then if you go down to
to line 18 notwithstanding
paragraph g1 banks and other financial
institutions may offer customers
investments productive services that
include subjective criteria as long as
they disclose it so that to me just sort
of pulls the rug out from under the
whole no no because
if you as a consumer say i only want
my
investments i'm going to take my
fifty thousand dollars in bitcoin and
now now that we're going to pass the
bitcoin law
and i'm gonna invest my fifty thousand
dollars and i only want it to go
into gun manufacturers fossil fuel
industries and uh whatever else
businesses
they can offer that as a product for you
because that's your investment strategy
that's your investment strategy they
offer the product they can do that there
are there are any number
you mentioned esg scores those are real
they exist companies have them there's
rate incomes you can go in and say i
only want companies with esg scores of
eight and above or however they're rated
uh you can they can offer that they can
do that just like i only want mutual
funds with a morning star rating of five
whoever right yep so you can do that
they can offer the product
you know what you're getting into
there's an agreement between the two of
you i only want companies that that do
this
but what they cannot do
is say
well
you drive
a car we think doesn't get good enough
gas mileage so
we're going to call your note we're
going to cut you off whatever else the
case may be
so
that's the kind of discrimination we
disagree with your politics we disagree
with you you own something that we don't
think you should own or you're investing
your money where we don't think you
should be investing it
we're trying to prevent that kind of of
discrimination
thank you
representative herbert okay so um
so if a pri if i'm in a private business
or i work for a private business
say a a tv station
and and i'm a newspaper reporter i've
been a a journalist and then i i come
out and and say something
that is
different from the ownership's point of
view
in terms of uh say politics
right
uh
i come out and say i hate bitcoin it
sucks and and the guy owns a bunch of
bitcoin and he says her you're fired
okay
i get that i know i get that i mean i've
been fired it's a private business
now you've narrowed the
target down to banking
am i correct
financial yeah
in business in business consumer
protection all business
all businesses who are not regulated by
this department so yeah so
all businesses
all right
now we got a freedom of speech issue i
think it goes beyond what you're talking
about
i could see
i mean we we
banks used to redline right
and so we got rid of that well
supposedly we got rid of it yep but this
would be this is this is redlining for
the 21st century
we are trying to prevent redlining in
just like we're trying to introduce
bitcoin it's not a greenback
it's new
it's it's something that we have to get
out in front of or there will be people
who will find themselves with no access
to the marketplace well my problem with
that is that uh
all the citations i'm given the examples
i'm given
for uh
suppression of somebody's voice
seem to be on the conservative side and
and and i and i'm and i'm thinking
you know
last time i looked uh you know we have a
republican legislature here in new
hampshire this is 19 states this is no
this is not republican versus democrat
well actually because you're protected
every bit as much as i am
because who who the the policies
can become subjective
so whoever is up here at the top that's
making the rules all of a sudden changes
somehow now now where you were okay and
i was not it switches you don't want my
guy discriminating against you just as
much as i don't want your guy
discriminating against me so let's tell
them both to go pound saying you can't
discriminate against either one of us
well okay i get it i get i get that but
but the fact of the matter is
discrimination cuts both ways
so for example today i listened to a
banking commission who has done 180
degrees on crypto and i'm going no no no
not the banking commission
the bankers association
bankers association don't confuse the
two did a very and and i'm not saying
they're not being thoughtful
i'm just saying i was a little surprised
they've been amenable to this
conversation since the beginning so i
wouldn't characterize the banking
association as being anti they had
concerns in the way the bill was written
because they were going to be on the
hook for the 5 million dollars so they
really weren't too crazy about that and
it wasn't 180 degrees they recognized
where they're already governed by the
ucc and they're going to be governed by
it in the future the difference is that
we're going to provide an hour later the
ucc and bitcoin is very recent
so
i you know we can have a discussion
about whether or not that was a change
but
what i'm trying to do do we want anybody
discriminating against anybody for any
reason
of course
we want people to discriminate
i have differences of opinion if you
want to but do you want to be penalized
for your difference of opinion
of course that happens all the time i'm
a democrat for christ's sake i hardly
ever win so i mean
somehow i feel like you guys were in the
majority a couple of times that i wasn't
sitting here
so
party politics just take you
whatever you are whatever you believe if
somebody says i'm not going to give you
access to the market because you
disagree with me
i'm cutting off your your your financial
your ability to purchase things i'm
going to cut off your ability to
grow
whatever i have never heard of anything
that you just mentioned the entire coal
and natural gas and petroleum industry
in this country is under attack right
now for this very reason it's all
politics
there's some serious disagreements there
you go in terms of uh what what the best
course of action is that's politics it's
democracy so i i we you and i might have
different opinions but do you want
anyone discriminating against anyone
because they have a different political
opinion
do you want anyone discriminating
against of course
how about your religion
should you be discriminated against
because of your religious rhetorical
questions it's not rhetorical we have it
codified in law because people were
discriminated against because of their
religion it's in the cause we also had
people discriminating against because of
their race and we also become
discriminated against because of their
gender
okay all right
discrimination we're trying to prevent
come on guys okay so you have you
respectively
disagree
yeah for sure
okay
keith
yeah just i don't know if this is a
rhetorical question or not but if i look
at that list it's uh on page 1 line 10
through 16
and again it's repeated on line 29 and
over to page two if i look at that list
what items are
you know
what items ideologically benefit one
side over the other and uh do they seem
fair and balanced because let's actually
talk about the text of the bill
so you know if you look at give me a
question
it's rhetorical you can answer if you
want but you know i don't see anything
here that but i was thinking in terms of
banking
so when i read what if we just look at
the bill very narrowly thinking about
banking
so if that list there does it favor one
ideological side over the other or is it
does it seem balanced i think that's
really the question that we should be
thinking about
well i think i think we have i think we
have a
a long tradition of how we settle those
arguments
and it's the ballot box and
and there has been discrimination uh
in our history for sure
so i'm not i'm not uh arguing against it
i'm just saying that
um we have to be very careful
uh that uh we make accusations about
what people do like take your car away i
think he made that accusation
uh because of uh somebody you know likes
guns i mean
i i don't i think you've just gone over
the bridge from my perspective
the law is not necessary
fair enough okay i can get it i get what
is upset about but can we hear from the
banking industry
do they have any comments about this
bank department
do you see this happening
even i didn't bring you up for this
okay chris turn off your mic so we can
free up the free up a
like
do you know of any case of
discrimination that would fit into one
of these categories that actually
occurred in new hampshire off the top of
my head i don't recall seeing any
consumer complaints regarding this
topic thank you
thank you emily
yes chris
um
thank you but
one of the things that i noticed in the
original bill
um it didn't mention
things like people of color or
transgender people and there was a big
difference there because there was
monetary
damages involved now that there's not
that's not such a big deal but why
weren't things like that put in because
we already have anti-discrimination but
understand that you may have those
anti-discrimination things but they
wouldn't have gotten the money
uh because they weren't listed in this
bill
and that's why i think this bill is
really not up to par that's why the
money's gone i'm sorry the money's gone
there's no money the money is on what's
in the current penalties under these two
statutes
that's the penalties again you you
all right
but i think that was they uh
they should have been placed in there
basically under the the current law
those kind of discrimination as well
uh they're pointedly not there and to me
that stuck out like a sore thumb
but now this is being added to that i
understand that but the original way it
was your point is somewhat well taken in
the sense that those anti-discrimination
statutes
are on somewhere else
so um we
i guess we could theoretically because i
know like for instance the the big
anti-description is um
is housing
it's uh um
the housing is a hell it's a housing or
pla actually it's a place of employment
but you can't discriminate
so we we could add to the list
we could add those to the list
i i think if you're going to
continue with this bill you ought to add
those things in
those type of descriptions more
discrimination categories okay
thank you
so get your vote
represent him yes um
thank you
um i agree there seems to be a lot of
categories not on this list
that could be causes for discrimination
so i think i would agree
that um
that the list should include
all of those other types of
discrimination that appear elsewhere
like race or
or um uh ethnic or age yeah i think
they're the reality the reason why they
didn't because they're already
right uh you know and and they're and
most of them are federal law right
they're they're gonna be they're all
covered under the federal law so and i
believe it is uh sexual orientation has
been added to that list
and and so theoretically the reason we
did that is because they they were
already
in the federal federal uh fair
loan fair credit act anyways but
um and and further are there any other
types of discrimination
you know that we missed other other
uh
feel free to add
i don't know off the top of my head but
um i you know seeing the gun ownership
there may be ownership of some other
things
that might um
cause a bank um
to maybe look at the loan differently
um so i i just hope
that that this list is fairly complete
for all those other
types of discrimination um
that are not
listed elsewhere in the law
okay
any other comment jd how what do you
think
once you come up to a mic so that so
anybody who watches youtube can hear you
until they
take our web page down
yes i think you've done a reasonable job
at putting together areas of
discrimination that are not covered
under current uh law
um i want to give an uh a a
an answer to the question of uh to mr uh
uh representative
bello
okay
i'm sorry with my french i don't do it
polio was french
so
the comment was that all all the
the discrimination
appears to be coming from a conservative
point of view but one could take the
abortion issue and and a bank that says
i'm not going to give you a loan because
you support abortion
is is
is an equal
discriminatory point of view that i
don't think you would be in favor of um
and and
and so
as the chairman has pointed out and and
other representatives here is is the
list is designed to to go both ways
irrespective of your political point of
view
you are not to be discriminated against
for that rationale
did you want to comment yeah i wanted to
comment um the way it was presented was
one-sided and uh so you know kudos to
the chair for
you know putting together an amendment
that makes it a little bit more
reasonable but just heard from the
banking industry and um
they have no issues they they haven't
had any any issues in new hampshire
regarding
this situation
so discrimination i'm i'm aware of two
individuals who have gone to a local
bank one is the hampstead kingston
republican town committee
wanted to find a place to to
place their
town committee funds
and they went to the local td bank and
the td bank folks said we're not dealing
with you because you republicans have
the wrong opinion on gun control
another individual went to the bank and
got a similar kind of reproach
now did they bring that to the banking
commission and advise them of that no
they just went to another bank and moved
on but that's the kind of thing that
should not be happening irrespective of
your point of view one way or the other
okay
uh since i still need to have a new
amendment we can't really vote on this
today so we'll take this up at 11 30.
on tuesday
it's wednesday it's gonna be february
2nd
and we'll see you all tomorrow with
with some public hearings thank you very
much and we close
the subcommittee
you